Jury selection begins
on Thursday in Dominion
Voting Systems
$1.6 billion defamation lawsuit
against Fox News.
Will Fox settle before
it goes to trial on April 17?
And either way, will
their viewers ever hear
anything about the emails
and texts revealed
by those in charge
that the network didn't
believe what it was actually airing?
Dominion
is accusing the network
of knowingly
and repeatedly airing falsehoods
about its voting machines rigging
the 2020 election in favor of Joe Biden
Among those
who are set to take the stand,
the network's
most prominent hosts like Sean
Hannity and Tucker
Carlson and high ranking
executives, including 92 year old
chairman Rupert Murdoch, himself.
Joining me now is Leigh Levine.
He's a veteran First Amendment lawyer
who when his long career
represented both Fox and CNN,
he's argued before the Supreme Court.
CNN's still uses his former firm,
and he once represented me years ago.
Leigh, nice to see you again.
Actual malice.
That's an awfully high bar
knowledge of falsity
or reckless disregard for the truth.
But this case seems to be capable
of meeting it. You agree?
Absolutely.
I've said this from the very
Stronger case of actual malice
than this one against the media entity.
A lot of the deposition testimony,
the texts and the emails
and the behind
the scenes has come to light
in media coverage of the pleadings.
Can that be imputed
to the company at large?
Can the company be held
accountable for what
Tucker Carlson
may have said to a colleague?
Well, you know, that's the big
very interesting thing, Michael,
about the judge's decision last week
allowing the case to go to trial.
The judge basically said
that that's an issue for the jury,
which means that dominion
can put into evidence all of that stuff
about all of those people.
And it will be up to the jury to decide
whether or not
any of it is relevant to Fox
as an entity, state of mind.
With respect to knowledge.
It ought to be a reckless
disregard of the truth.
You know this as well. As I do.
That is a tremendous boon for Dominion
Can the
defendant in this case, Fox News,
wrap themselves in opinion?
Can they sell what we were just
this was an item of of news interest
and we were putting someone on air
to express their opinion.
We didn't necessarily buy into it.
They cannot the judge took
that argument by Fox off the table.
In his decision
that was released last week.
So the jury is going to be instructed
that Fox broadcast false statements
of fact
about Dominion that were defamatory.
The only issue in this regard before
the jury
is whether or not Fox published it
with knowledge of falsity
or recklessness.
Regarding the truth
and who we were at Fox,
whose state of mind
with respect to truth
or falsity is relevant.
Those are really
the only issues other than damages
that the jury is going to
be asked to decide.
If you were defending the case,
what would you be leading with
That's really tough.
I think that I would be leading
with trying to
blow holes in the connecting dots
between the various people
who said things about Sidney Powell
being not Rudy
Giuliani being crazy or not
believing the truth
and what the line producers and the hosts
knew at the time.
But given the evidence
that's in the case,
it's going to be hard
to blow holes in that line.
So if I were a defense lawyer
handling this case, I wouldn't
I would be really worrying about what
I could do by way of defense.
It sounds to me
like you'd be recommending
you'd be laying out
the pluses and minuses,
but perhaps recommending that
they settle.
Yeah, I would
if I were asked for a recommendation,
I would recommend settlement.
I'm surprised that
the case has not settled so far.
I'm surprised it didn't settle before.
Or Fox
had to produce
all of these emails and texts
that have now become public.
I'm surprised
they didn't settle after the briefing
when all of this was laid
out to the public.
My
my only thought now is
if they're waiting for jury selection
to see what kind of jury they draw
and whether they feel comfortable
that they're
at least
a person or two on that jury
who might not
be interested in ruling against Fox.
That's the only thing I can think
That process
scheduled to begin on Thursday.
Lee Levine, thank you so much.
Nice to see you.
Good to see you, too. Michael, take care.
Checking in
on social media reaction What do we have
Fox should be required
by the jury to admit to their viewers
how Fox deceived them.
This requirement
should preface the beginning
of every TV segment
that airs on Fox hour by hour.
You raise citizen Jenn.
You raise a very interesting question,
which is,
you know,
if a tree falls in the forest,
is the Fox View viewer
even going to know about this?
The case has gotten
extensive publication in the media,
but it doesn't get discussed at all
on Fox News.
Even if the case is to resolve
with a big check being written,
which I anticipate,
will their viewers be any the wiser?
And by the way, in some far
right media quarters,
they've not even taken the lesson
from the judge
who used all caps in explaining
that there is absolutely no basis
for any of that
which was said about dominion.
In other words,
people are not learning the lesson,
at least yet,
from what has come out in this case.